all right well i cannot believe this
first of all two legends who have made
me laugh for decades this is the best
christmas gift ever along with this film
like i can't even believe this kathy you
have been an ally you know forever and
thank you for that but when you were
approached with this film was it almost
a no-brainer for you to be part of it
yeah i mean that was a huge part of it i
really love the fact that we've seen
like countless christmas movies which i
love christmas so i'm in for that but
i love the fact that it's about uh a
romance
and it's uh between uh two men i'm not
gonna say which men because they haven't
seen it yet but um but that it's not
about them being gay it's just about
christmas time and a family and to and
anybody could be anybody flirting with
anybody kissing anybody so i really i
know that that's not the norm for
society for a lot of people lgbtq plus
people um but it was really refreshing
to have the story just be about
christmas and dating and not about the
issue was not that they were gay guys
yeah that is something that i loved
about it too there wasn't an acceptance
part it was just it's just a happy
family who love and support each other
jennifer you are a gay icon the gays are
always obsessed with you much like your
character in this film who mentions
grindr so it got me thinking if you were
to give some advice to single gays out
there opening up a grinder profile what
would you suggest to them
um i suggest um putting an animal in the
shot
an animal so you wouldn't say like bare
chest or like a koi pose oh no of course
no but no but i always have to be you
know not a lot of clothes but i just
feel like when you put
the animal in with like one of these hot
guys put their dog in whatever i don't
know why you can just get so many more
hits you are so right about that kathy i
love that your character sets uh your
son up on a blind date have either of
you ever been on a blind date and how
did that turn out
i have never been on a blind date i wish
i had a charming clever answer for you
but i
i really haven't been on lots of dates
i'm not a dater i just happen to meet
somebody and then if it works i'm like
okay good for eight years that's good
jennifer have you been on a blind date
before
yes uh yeah my friend chase set me up
with this guy and um
uh
he had the same hair style as hillary
clinton
and um
and um
but what was funny was uh he uh
he sat to my right and then the table
beyond
our table was these two women sitting
and he just talked to them the whole
time
what's that all about
i'm on a mission to make christmas 2021
the queerest christmas ever what can you
suggest to people to you know bring out
the gayness of the holidays
first of all you have to make a bumper
sticker that says the queerest christmas
ever
yeah you're right
i don't know jennifer how can we make it
the queerest holiday ever
i mean it's already you know the elves
come on the elves let's start
stockings knee-high socks little heels
we've got those on our sides
you're right it is already pretty queer
you know what it does you know it's just
i think when i saw uh
how cardi b uh decorated her house for
christmas last year
i was like
you know i feel like you know she might
have outdone the gays and i think we
might have to step it up i think you
might be right very quickly kathy listen
uh seeing that picture of you bette
midler and sarah jessica parker together
again for hocus pocus 2 literally
brought a tear to my eye because that
film
has been with me for
forever uh how has it been reuniting
with them and are you excited for people
to see this second
well we just started filming so i'm not
sure if i'm excited yet but i'm sure
it's going to be great um you know i got
to tell you it it came out in the summer
a halloween movie and so it didn't do
great and so it really found its legs on
on tv so it's a huge surprise to all
three of us
that it had this resurrection and that
uh people are so madly in love with it i
mean i
i just made a funny face and and uh was
was lucky to be with uh two really funny
people
you did a lot more than that thank you
so much you're both icons thank you for
everything over the years and yeah this
was a great christmas gift
thank you
bye sweetheart bye